[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous
je suis un peu surpris parce qu'on
m'avait dit qu'on était en petit comité
puis au final ben vous êtes beaucoup
plus que prévu donc ça rajoute un petit
peu de stress
mais bon on va y aller moi je suis venu
ce soir pour raconter une histoire
cette histoire c'est la mienne mais
cette histoire ça peut être aussi celle
de n'importe qui d'entre vous l'objectif
ce soir c'est de venir parler d'un
parcours et que vous puissiez chacun
chacune à votre tour dans un moment de
la période de la vie je vais vous
raconter prendre ce qui est pour vous
prendre ce qu'il fait résonance en vous
et qui vous fait avancer
pour commencer une histoire j'aimerais
commencer par par l'enfance intérêts
qu'il faut commencer par la mort ce sera
un peu moins drôle donc on va commencer
par l'enfance imaginez moi un bon bout
plus petits avec des cheveux tout blond
clair coupe au bol comme ça sur la tête
en plus de ça un petit bonhomme avec une
voix super aiguë et qui parle dans le
temps
j'ai souvent on me disait tu es
sacrément pana bavard pour un petit
bonhomme et ben vingt ans après ça a pas
changé je suis toujours aussi bavard
ce petit garçon eh ben en plus des
bavards il était très curieux et dans sa
curiosité il observait les gens autour
de lui son moyen de s'adapter au monde
c'était de visualiser ce qui se passait
autour de lui pour comprendre et pouvoir
se comporter en fonction et ce petit
garçon qui avait envie de parler et
plein de questions questionné souvent
les adultes sur le sait quoi le sens de
ça c'est quoi le mot que tu viens
d'utiliser je suis pas vraiment sûr de
comprendre ce que tu dis est là les
adultes surtout et des fois un peu
concernée va cet enfant qui avaient des
questions d'adultes pour un petit enfant
et à côté de sa curiosité et de son
amour pour les mots ce petit garçon est
bien c'était quelqu'un de très sensible
l'allemand qui avait tendance à
exprimer ses émotions assez fortement
que ce soit la tristesse la colère ou la
joie c'était criant qui était quand même
assez expressif tout en étant très
timide et réservé ce petit garçon est
agrandie et les allées à l'école et à
l'école il s'est rendu compte que ça
serait beaucoup moins facile qu'à la
maison la confrontation avec les autres
élèves la confrontation au sentiment
d'échec la cour de récré à la cour de
récré j'étais plutôt copain avec des
filles régler fils était plus douce
était c'est plus
plus sensible dans les jeux les garçons
à l'oeuf la boxe le basket le foot et se
cogner
c'était pas forcément ma tasse de thé et
à côté en classe j'étais un enfant
encore plus timide parce que face et
fallait surtout pas se mettre en avant
donc j'écoutais ce qui se passait et se
passait en place et souvent s'il y avait
une question qui était posée j'avais la
réponse mais je me retenais de lever la
main pour y répondre parce que je me
disais que dans la classe y aurait bien
deux ou trois personnes solidaires qui
auraient la bonne réponse qui
répondraient qui répondrait à ma place
c'était la plupart du temps ce qui a été
fait les autres répondait à ma place
mais ça n'empêchait pas d'eux quand même
accueilli la matière et de fer eu des
bonnes notes et ce petit garçon genk
écouter en classe était aussi un grand
rêveur j'aimais rêver en classe mais
j'aimerais arriver aussi au petit déj
jamais rêvé sur le chemin du retour pour
la maison et puis j'aimais bien arriver
aussi le soir quand avec mon frère on
avait fini se chamailler et qu'enfin on
dormait à 23h30 alors qu'on était
couchée à 20h30 et mes parents après
trois coups de pied dans la porte et
éradique les deux petits blancs de la
pièce du fond s'endorme
et ce petit garçon et ben
les perdu le fil
ce petit garçon oui je disais voilà
rêver beaucoup et le rêve de ce petit
garçon c'était un monde où il y avait de
l'amour de la compassion du rêve et
surtout de l'intérieur de la tolérance
de chacun et chacune est du coup c'était
vraiment une bulle dans laquelle dans
laquelle je vivais et j'ai continué à
grandir avec avec cette bulle avec
toujours cette hypersensibilité super
présente et je ne compte plus le nombre
de fois où mes parents sont venus me
chercher à l'école parce que j'étais en
larmes et que les profs trouvé que gt
est trop émotif et souvent on m'a dit
mon petit garçon il va falloir que tu
sois fort si tu veux pouvoir suivre dans
le monde dans lequel on vit alors
comment ils avaient entre sept et huit
ans et que on vous dit ça
qu'est ce que je peux être faire pour
être fort eh ben j'ai trouvé une idée
je me suis rendu dans ma garde-robe
et j'ai sorti mon costume de petit
garçon fort je les prie
je les enfiler up super maintenant j'ai
un petit garçon de huit ans mais en plus
je suis fort et puis pour être fort
parce que les biskotos c'est comme
aujourd'hui il y en avait pas beaucoup
qu'est-ce que je peux faire eh ben je
peux faire rire j'avais remarqué en
observant les gens que le rire masquer
la tristesse et que le rire est bien
faisait penser qu on était bien et puis
que du coup on était tout le temps
joyeux donc j'ai adopté mon costume de
petit garçon fort et on puisse j'ai
adopté là sourires attitude aussi tu es
super chouette d'avoir un petit garçon
blond qui parle tout le temps et qu'on
puisse et souriant donc pour pourrir au
quotidien c'était septembre et à bhl et
ses petits garçons il a grandi et il est
arrivé dans l'adolescence avec tout ce
qui inclut à de l'essence déjà on
commence avec la cne ensuite les cheveux
gras
après il ya les hormones qui travaillent
les premières relations
amoureuse et bien entendu les premières
déceptions amoureuses et à l'adolescence
en fait je me suis rendu compte que ben
en fait je n'ai pas une fille enfin oui
je l'aimé beaucoup de copines pour aller
faire les magasins et puis pour rigoler
sur un caillou en sortant de l'école
mais j'étais pas forcément amoureux des
filles mais par contre le garçon la
classe parallèle je crois que j'aurais
bien donner la main à lui fallait quand
même resté un peu discret toujours dans
cet objectif de rester fort et souriant
et quand même dans la vision
d'adolescents rêveur puisque
l'adolescent reste rêveur je me disais
ouais alors aimer dans ce monde c'est
cool mais dans le vrai monde
c'est pas comme ça en fait dans le vrai
monde vingt deux garçons qui s'aiment
c'est mal vu vous imaginez que mon
adolescence s'est passé c'est se passer
en 2010 2011 aujourd'hui heureusement
les choses ont avancé mais en 2010-2011
si vous tapiez coming out sur internet
on vous disait tu vas te faire [ __ ]
dehors alors bon chez avec mes parents
mais beaucoup mais
on va pas venait d'un milieu paysan et
je me disais bon ben si papa une foule
dehors ça va pas être drôle donc je me
suis dit bon mais je vais garder ça pour
moi et puis je vais avancer avec ça donc
mon amoureux pedro était devenu pauline
c'était très bien alors alibi tip top
tous les week-ends j'allais voir pauline
bunge épaté plus que trois mois et puis
au bout de trois mois j'ai craqué et
puis j'ai dit bon voilà il faut que je
parle à mes parents il faut que je leur
dise il faut que je puisse être qui je
suis quand même alors j'ai annoncé à mes
parents
c'est dit lem les garçons bon c'est bien
passé heureusement j'ai pas dû quitter
la maison mon papa l'a très bien pris ma
maman aussi et jamais été chassés fin
vraiment même juin d'une fratrie de
trois garçons et puis c'est passé
vraiment tip top donc malgré ce que
disait internet je me rendais compte que
quand même dont le monde familial
c'était c'était possible mais je me suis
confronté en fait au monde extérieur au
monde extérieur j'ai vu que là c'était
beaucoup moins bien perçu petite
anecdote
ce toujours ce petit ami pedro capital
dans la région lausannoise à l'époque un
matin sur le quai de la gare on
s'embrasse pour se dire au revoir
et là en fait une maman fait comme ça
elles cachent les yeux de sa fille bon
moi ça me choque un peu et là une dame
âgée est pour part dire vieille dame ont
quand même vient vers elle et
l'interpellent comme ça on désormais
vous n'avez pas honte puis la maman ce
bras comme ça mais quoi de quoi j'ai ont
de quoi je devrais avoir honte et vous
n'avez pas honte de rendre votre fille
intolérante et puis bon après je
pourrais pas vous dire le reste parce
que bon on est monté dans le train et
puis on est on est parti mais cet
épisode mais donner un petit espoir en
disant voilà le monde à l'extérieur
n'est pas facile mais il ya quand même
des gens qui sont acteurs de de cet
amour parce que pour moi c'était de
l'amour puis l'amour ça reste ça reste
de l'amour pour ce que c'est et puis
justement en grandissant on arrive dans
l'âge adulte et puis ben l'âge adulte
l'amour ça se concrétise un peu c'est
plus juste de trois textos une amourette
une balade en scooter et puis une soirée
un samedi soir ça devient un petit peu
plus sérieux et à l'époque ben
je vivais une relation d'amour
mais je savais pas c'est que l'amour ça
pouvait signifier
commentaires
remarques
insultes et souvent les coups ça on
n'allait pas dire et dans la vision du
rêve du petit garçon de 7 ans et ben ils
pensaient pas que l'amour c'était ça
donc dans le petit nid que vous créez
votre petit nid d'amour avec la personne
que vous aimez le plus à qui vous donnez
tous votre coeur enfin toute l'énergie
que vous avez à donner et ben là vous
rentrez dans un climat de violence ou
tout ce que vous faites est épié ce que
vous dites est dévalorisé et on vous
demande d'être différent de ce que vous
êtes
et puis vint la malheureusement le
costume
de jeune adulte fort et est un peu
fatigué ça suffisait pas et puis le
sourire ça marchait très bien à
l'extérieur mais à l'intérieur nous
avoue que c'était pas terrible louis va
les trouver autre chose
qu'est ce que je pourrais bien trouvé
que ce soit facile que personne ne se
pose la question et que ça se passe bien
et ben moi
j'ai choisi l'alcool d'abord le week-end
puis le vendredi soir le jeudi soir
mercredi soir mardi soir lundi soir le
midi puis tout le temps puis trop puis
beaucoup trop et abandonner la violence
l'alcool à côté sans développer on
rajoute des problèmes au travail eh ben
ça fait un cocktail un peu molotov et du
coup à ce moment là ben vous êtes comme
ça pour garder face au miroir et ça
craque le costume craque le mas qui
tombe l'être humain complet explose et
là c'est un tas de débris retrouvés par
terre et stade débris
bon c'était moi et puis ben qu'est ce
que je fais avec ça maintenant ce tas de
débris si je regarde un peu violence
alcool peur quand
triste scolaire pas très bon de repartir
sur le même modèle en
bon alors voilà vous vous retrouvez face
au miroir et puis vous dites bon bah mon
gars là en face de moi qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant et puis voilà vous
comprenez qu'en fait lire quelque chose
en vous qui demeure qui demeure ici dans
votre coeur ce qui demeure ici c'est ce
que vous visualisez ce que ce que vous
visualisez dans votre tête c'est votre
rêve c'est ce à quoi vous aspirez c'est
ce que vous avez envie de vivre et moi
ce jour là quand j'ai eu cet électrochoc
quand j'ai pris conscience qu'en fait ma
vie n'était devenu qu'un débris et ben
je me suis dit il faut que je me batte
j'ai envie que ce soit mieux qu'à ce
moment-là et baloji voilà il faut faire
évoluer mon monde il faut faire évoluer
le monde qu'il ya autour de moi et du
coup et bien depuis ce jour là j'ai
choisi de mettre chaque pierre à
l'édifice chaque jour pour que le monde
soit meilleur pour le mien mais aussi
pour les autres et c'est ça qui anime
aujourd'hui les actions que je fais les
paroles que que je peux avoir
ce que je fais aussi pour moi de bons
pour moi de bon pour les autres c'est
justement pour propager sa pour propager
en fait cette image de rêve et dire tu
vois c'est possible moi j'y suis arrivé
je suis pas meilleur que vous rappelez
vous que jeune adulte je n'étais qu'un
tas de débris alors je caricature un
petit peu j'étais pas que ça mais c'est
l'image que j'avais j'étais plus que ça
et en fait de me reconnecter à ce qui
sommeille en moi et parce qu'ils se
méfiaient au petit garçon blond à la
coupe au bol bavard et 20 du coût eh ben
ça faisait sens et ça me donnait un
chemin
pour avancer et
pour clore cette histoire
j'aimerais vous faire vivre une petite
expérience à chacun et à chacune d'entre
vous si bien sûr vous êtes d'accord avec
ça je vois pas mais j'aimerais vous
inviter chacune et chacun d'entre vous a
fermé les yeux un petit instant
et puis quand vous avez fermé les yeux
je vous invite à les rencontrer
cet enfant que vous étiez
et cet enfant que vous étiez vous invite
à visualiser le rêve que cet enfant
arrêts
et quand vous avez les deux je vous
invite à visualiser l'adulte que vous
êtes aujourd'hui
et dans sept adultes quel est son rêve
aujourd'hui
quand vous avez fait cette connexion
je vous invite à voir si le rêve de
l'enfant est le même que le rêve de
l'adulte
et quand vous avez pu visualiser ça vous
pouvez gentiment rouvrir les yeux
reprendre conscience de l'espace nous
sommes des gens qui sont autour de vous
et la présence de l'ici et maintenant
et pour terminer j'aimerais me permettre
une titre familiarité je me dis ça fait
une quinzaine de minutes qu'on est
ensemble et puis par rex est assez
coutumier dans la région de se tutoyer
donc j'aimerais te dire à toi à toi à
toi et à toi et à toutes les personnes
qui puis qui sont là et qui pourront
voir cette vidéo que moi j'ai suivi la
lumière qui avaient en moi mais que toi
aussi tu peux suivre cette lumière est
en fait que la lumière qui sommeille en
toi c'est là qu'est la liberté merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]